[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maitere fait surprise là alors le
partenaire des plats ou bien vous
n'aviez pas d'imagination
y a rien sur ce plateau n'y a pas de
viande n'est pas toujours riche ya pas
poissons les petits trucs qui se courent
après mais attention nous irons à bangui
les sites ikea là dedans c'est pas de ta
mère c'est quelque chose de bon vieux et
on nous on va le faire on va le faire
devant vous on va exécuter les recettes
devant vous et on va vous prouver avec
peu de chance on peut faire quelque
chose de bon voilà qui vous rappeler
quelque chose ou plutôt quelqu'un ça
serait pas j'ai croisé quelques parrains
choses un peu vers bull a alors alors
alors j'avais il n'aime pas trop les
femmes et surtout par les femmes comme
vous conforter les palets vieille de
vieille fille nous on ne vous inquiétez
pas vous mais nous on va on va faire la
recette nous mêmes on va montrer devant
vous tous comment on fait quelque chose
de bon comment on fait une tarte à la
mort elle la mode y un monde à elle là
ça vous devriez également d'enquêter en
italie
alors dites-moi maïté ya rien quoi il ya
des tomates si sa tomate européenne tout
pareil tout cas me paraît tout calibre
et il faut faire avec
il y en a c'est sa pauvreté aujourd'hui
ça c'est quoi déjà
ça n'avait pas l'europe mais rien ne
vaut le verdon ça va ça pousse sur le
balcon arrière destination c'est bon
c'était utile voilà est trop distancer
du vrai c'est pas dans les jeux ils
viennent de votre poulailler du
poulailler de chez moi
les ondes yves des andes et la belgique
où c'est pourquoi c'est du calibre de
finale aussi on en a nous y en a en
france ont annoncé et alors cette espèce
de mode ya longtemps que nous la
connaissons car elle n'avait pas
tellement longtemps mais c'est bon vous
aimez c'est bon sylvie français du
fromage de but olala bon alors ça serait
très bien mais moi je vais beaucoup sur
la prendre je peux pas que c'est tout
moi bon temps avec trois fois rien on va
faire quatre sets
alors quelle sera la première recette
une tarte à la mozzarella automates
que faut-il faire en premier à beurrer
le moule
oui c'est ça après j'ai étaler la pâte
qui est une pâte brisée qui ne pas te
briser que tout le monde se faire
annoncer à faire la pâte brisée
mills est pas prise et pardon oui alors
vous me mettez ça si vous voulez manger
un peu moins large et le petit peu oui
moi pendant ce temps je vais mettre les
lardons à cuire parce qu'il faut gélard
dans la voilà ça y est il faut couper un
peu les barres quand même un oui ou
alors qu'un petit est d'accord ça une
compétition les joueurs et ça va aller
voilà c'est vrai que j'ai été là et voir
si bon après 90 mettre dedans alors un
petit prince abdul a priori toujours
trouvé un petit peu de la moutarde un
petit peu de moutarde qu'on va étaler
badigeonner mai par rapport à mai mais
faut pas exagérer ce sera encore un
petit peu comme la vous êtes un peu mais
je vous dis que c'est le jour de la
pauvreté aussi là je vous sens non non
non pas d'humeur généreuse
la voilà voilà ensuite on prend les
tomates la viande avec lui bien que vous
voulez me regarder
oui avec plaisir au bout sa part un bon
justin dorey qu un petit peu voilà
c'était très vite fait on va décider
vous n'avez pas besoin de faire du décor
à fosses qu'il produit on s'applique
alors la mozza la7 surpris morale me
darel là et pas mozzarelle n'y croit pas
on ne dirait pas c'est pourquoi on ne
dirait pas mozzarella on peut le dire et
là vous intercalé c'est un peu partout
oui tous genres dire nous fait l'europe
de la cuisine facile j'en reviens pas
moi même
moi je trouve qu'ils sont assez doré
maintenant ça suffit pas pour le lait
oui oui les sens du feu bon une autre
peau matelas et 6 dont peu de mozzarelle
là j'aurais pu faire mieux que ferrat
s'appartient pas mieux faire vous allez
mettre dessus c'est quand même pas finie
la dont le sel du poivre
un petit peu au mas automates oui un
petit peu
il ya un petit pékin où il ya un truc
qui est bon très bien les lardons ou qui
serait bien qu'il vienne olalalala ça va
bien arrangé la pauvreté du plat ne fait
pas parler jambon de pays qu'on ne fait
pas une affaire de voir une tranche de
jambon dynamique quand même nom nous
ruiner et ensuite les patous 1 et
ensuite on va mettre des petites herbes
voilà lors il dort l'origan et oui et
après de base y vit pendant ce temps
naturellement on a mis le four à
chauffer à bien sûr bien chaud et voilà
regarder s'avoue opticiens mais pas
l'eau à faire savoir le fait on va bien
rangé il faut savoir
voilà comme une femme à la main les
jeunes c'est à dire que maïté pendant
que c'est cuit 25 millions proposés on
va faire une salade de quoi je me
rappelle plus je crois que vous aviez
dit que vous faisiez un premier jalon de
nous avoir la volonté d'un livre que
vous faut-il pas grand chose pas pousse
un peu naïve quelques patates une patate
de la grèce chose et on va faire cuire
n'était pas de complexe ne revienne là
regardez moi ça il ya la poker l'a alors
est par contre et génie du bouillon un
bouillon de bryant reeves a pas gâcher
la fête alors là je vais y rajouter les
patates ou non pas te économique comme
un petit peu bah oui pour qui la crise
de très vite
je vais déjà 10 du poids après 3 la
première fois que je vois le soudan
minus quand même c'est bon c'est très
ferme
c'est très flatteur d'écouté pour la
division ça vous a donné envie de faire
simple comme le dit le monsieur barbu ou
là il faut faire ça déborde h f
après ça mais on y arriver mais bien sûr
là et la jouer bientôt du bouillon il
leur faut pas trop quand même et parce
qu'il faut que ce soit c'est un velouté
il faut que ce soit fait il faut que ce
soit est fait pour mériter ça l'arrière
combien de temps cette affaire là d'une
minute dix minutes avant de faire la
troisième recette bisous oui la salade à
la mort et la mode y un bon 10 avril là
je n'y arriverais ça mais oubliez pas
vous êtes social à rennes aujourd'hui
monde
non c'est bien voilà mais c'est un plat
froid à leur maillot oui on peut la
commander chaud et froid
la marelle la villa garnier pantois ses
airs de maïté que votre récente
découverte de l'italie de la cuisine
italienne nous amène à faire des choses
étonnantes et la prononciation plus je
vais faire des progrès pour ça va venir
très très très très vite tout va alors
vous avez j'avais de plus vite que je
peux voilà est très bien aussi j'espère
la et des mois un peu ça y est c'est bon
et alors qu'est ce que vous allez mettre
dessus vous me disiez que vous aviez des
trucs la basilique du basilic link en
petit boulot c'est bon aujourd'hui voilà
c'est bien travaillé avec sa verrière ni
fait ni à faire aujourd'hui c'est pour
nous c'est bon ça y est
la voilà j'en suis je mets le buzz oui
grossièrement hachées c'est vrai je ne
me fais pas habiter les olives noires ça
fait joli shoot ou amazon et apparaît
alors alors je mets du sel du poivre
toujours pareil la vie voilà du vinaigre
e ri up diana c'est vrai qu'elle
aujourd'hui david olive
bien sûr oh la la le voilà des communes
hier là vous allez tout y est un peu je
tout y est ça y est
et la season les assaisonne et c'est
très simplement et très rond et
maintenant je crois qu'il est temps
d'aller voir celle qui est au four
qu'elle est devenue un mode arène la
chaude la tarte
voilà on va la chercher elle vous paraît
bien maïté moi elle est parfaite
joli ça lui permet quoi appétissante à
souhait mais il reste à déterminer le
velouté dans le velouté d'endives
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire je
vous la mettez pas ou qu'est ce qu'on va
faire ça va très vite fait regardez
c'est joli on voit le vide et la doda et
et à passer au presse-purée évidemment
oui voilà voilà
il ne reste plus qu'à la passe et je
tourne si vous voulez histoire d'endives
là c'est excellent parce que le
bouillant est très bon
elle continue à toute vitesse à la
grande énergie là ça passe ou ça va très
bien ça fait qu'une soupe inhabituel
mais qui va être délicieuse il y avait
voulu toute la semaine les développeurs
à venir pour qu'il répare toutes sortes
bien sûr je crois que là bas qu un assez
pour aujourd'hui vous savez ça fait déjà
un bon gardien va bien épaisse
bon on enlève ça alors regardez tout ce
qu'on a fait avec si peu de choses sur
la table une bonne consistance
elle est finie la soupe ou pas alors là
j'ai un oeuf un jaune d'or jaune d'oeuf
je vais y mettre sa crème fraîche de
d'armes ce qui ne va rien gâcher ça on
dit que c'est pour lier les velouté
qu'on adore regarder ça ben oui c'est
délicieux délicieux jus c'est délicieux
c'est bon ça et si tout on peut rajouter
un petit coucou à long terme il peut de
par nos âmes et voilà je crois qu'on n'a
plus qu'à présenter les trois plats oui
ça on a fait la cuisine rapide la
cuisine européenne et avec peu de choses
avec peu de choses alors et c'est simple
comme nous dit et c'est facile et je
vais le faire et voilà et voilà avec un
tri à la mozzarella et la salade froide
mozzarella et le velouté d'endives et
ben ne nous dit pas qu'on vous a pas
donné d plat facile agréable pas coûteux
dit merci au revoir à bientôt
au revoir à bientôt
[Musique]